♪
♪♪
♪♪♪
♪♪♪♪
♪♪♪♪♪
♪♪♪♪♪♪
！
…………
！？！？
うｎ？
ｷﾞｬｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ
はじめ「ｷﾞｬｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱ」
？？？「ｷﾞｬｧｧｧｧｧｧｧ」
ぴよよん
お前はﾀﾞﾚﾀﾞ!
はい
君の名は。
それ映画ですね
君の名はｗｗｗ
映画です　それ
こんないい日に何してんのさ
(ﾌﾞｰｰｰﾝ)
ん？
o----i
ano-
e?
たぶん ふざけてますよね？
見て楽しいですか～
ﾔﾀﾞ!!!
うｎ？
なんか怖いモン顔～<`～´>
う？
お前どこから来たんだ?
ｵﾚ~？
ぅわったしは～かわぬぉかみだ～
ｳﾙｻｰｲ
なんで？
あなた神なんですか？
この地域の川の神よ～
ﾊｧﾝ
なんでｱｰっつったの
はじめ「くらえ！」
川の神「ヤメテ！」
神様こんなところで何してるんですか？
何もクソもこの辺の主よ
あなた今ひなたぼっこしてる感じですか？
ひなたぼっこ
SOUYO!!!
SO!
HINATAB"A"KK...
HINA....
ひなたぼっこよ
怒ってますか？！！？！！
怒ってないじゃん...
その顔で？！
SOUYO
ぜったい怒ってるヨ！
元々こういう生まれ
ｱｯﾊｯﾊ<`～´>
ｱｧﾝ?
ﾊｧ????
ｱｧｧﾝ??
ｱｧｧｧﾝ??
ｱ゛ｧｧｧｧｧｧ???
ｱ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛!!!
ｱ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛↑↑↑↑↑
ｳ゛ﾜ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛!゛!゛!゛!゛
ｳ゛ﾜ゛ｨ゛ﾔ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛!゛
ｵ゛ﾎﾞ゛ﾛ゛ﾛ゛ﾛ゛ﾛ゛ﾛ゛ﾛ゛$%&#$%&$#$
ﾎﾞﾛ゛ﾎﾞﾛ゛ﾎﾞﾛ゛ﾎﾞﾛ゛#$%$#
＿人人人人人人人人人人人人人人人人人人人人人人＿
＞ ﾎﾞﾛﾎﾞﾛﾎﾞﾛﾎﾞﾛﾎﾞﾛﾎﾞﾛァァァ"#$%&%$#"$%$#"#$ ＜
￣Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^Y^￣
ヤベーッ近所やべ～
近所やべえ
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊ(^^)/
おじいちゃん超見てる
ぉおじいちゃん超見てる
やべやべぇ
考えて下さいよ神様
ﾊｨﾊｲ
他者から見たらボク
川に話しかけてるだけですからね　大声で
で、ｱ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛って言ってんでしょ
っそうwwww
ヤバイ奴だね
川に一人で向かって
ｱ゛ｧ゛ｧ゛って言ってるだけですからね
新しいネ申だねぇ
ときにはじめよ(唐突)
あぁはぃ
あのぉ～
…………
なんか言い辛いんだけど
あぁなんでも
言ってくださいよ
……………………
泳げないから助けてぇ？
んぅ
弱点
あれでも
ドラゴンタイプって
草効いたっけ？
たぶんドラゴンタイプじゃなくても
痛ぁいよ
ほんで助けて
んん？
みなさ～～～ん
はじめくんが～～～
黙秘権を使いました～～
ﾔﾒﾛ~~
ぼｒぼｒｂろｂｒっろｒｂろｒ
ぼろｒｂろｒｂろｂｒｂろｒぼｒ
ｒぼろｒｂろｂろおｂろｂｒｒｒｧｧｧｧｧ
あ、コンニチハ～
へ
あ～ちょっごめ
え
おじ…おじいちゃんにあいさつしてた・・・
あ、おじいちゃんか
とりあえず君を助ければいいんだね？
はい！おねがいしますぅ
しかたね～たすけてやろ～
ワァァァァ⤵
ありがとうございまｓ...
ひゅぴーん☆彡
ちなみにィ
正体は...
はいっ
赤いｷﾞｬﾗﾄﾞｽでした~wwww
U☆ZA☆I
!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
あはっはっはっはっはｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
カラーリング!!www
あはっはっはｗｗｗ
UZE~~!!!wwwww
wwwwwwwwww
それうぜぇwww